i look at the cheap money chart here i
mean everything is about cheap money
cheap money today how much is the great
distortion of your economic world the
reason we're talking about dinosaurs
mating and capable money's free isn't it
well that's clearly one of the forces
behind the m a wave
but you know we have those low rates
because uh as stan fisher was saying we
are concerned about the state of the
economy uh the m a and other
implications are sort of secondary at
least from the fed's perspective their
focused on whether they can help bring
down the unemployment you worry that the
financial engineering within our great
distortion benefits people like john
malone and that it's all going to the
elite who are smart enough to do
transactions and to benefit in finance
while everybody else including cable
bill
providers what is it 150 200 bucks that
is actually the best way to think of
them people build providers not evil
services people no but people writing
out the check every month they're
getting hammered within this great
distortion aren't they well look
stepping back from that we've had
two to three decades now of rising
inequality a key question is
why and what we can do about it and one
of the interesting things is most of the
rhetoric is about
ceo versus average pay
the evidence actually suggests that most
of the rise in wage inequality is
because pay at say apple on average
diverges from pay at mcdonald's on
average not within firm inequality okay
that's really that's accused are you
going to write about this i've written
about it once actually there's a brand
new paper out this morning from the
national bureau of economic
reinforcing i just saw that
okay
we'll write about this number 16 on the
nbr list this week okay very good that's
what we're looking at
speeches on friday for mario draghi and
janet yellen they both talked a lot
about productivity but i noticed that
jenny ellen spent about three paragraphs
on
state spending that she really talked
about there she believes that there's
still a drag
on the money that states are willing to
put into the economy it was interesting
to hear her you know several years after
the the recession still talking about
that is that still a factor for you it
absolutely is and we see that in uh it's
not the majority of states but there's a
clear minority of states that are still
implementing contractionary policies and
it shows up in lots of different ways
one of the things that i think is most
concerning over the long term is that
states have been cutting back on
appropriations for higher education
public universities have not been able
to offset that despite the big tuition
increases that they put in place have
not been able to offset that over the
past 25 years the quality of our public
universities relative to private
universities has deteriorated
significantly over the past 30 years
we've had one alex sherman to bring it
back to this transaction at the moment
one of the raging debates over the
barbecue this weekend was the idea of is
the internet good for kids and the idea
is to peter's point the internet can
make a lot of kids smarter with access
to knowledge does chartering time warner
cable use the broadband debate when they
try to get this thing approved
absolutely comcast was trying and failed
john malone is going to say to simplify
this john malone's going to say if you
let us merge we're going to provide
better internet to make poor kids
smarter right it will provide better
cheaper internet perhaps in regions of
the country that still don't have rob
internet which actually does exist in
large swaths of the country you don't
have access still to high-speed
broadband internet because it hasn't
been cost efficient for the cable
companies to build it there that may
slowly start to erode and it will be a
big chip to throw to the obama
administration to say look we'll do this
and then all these people will get
access that haven't had it before alex
sherman thank you